à pèse terriblement certains disent que
ce sont des augmentations de 30 voire de
100% parce que il ya aussi la volatilité
du marché c'est à dire comme vous devez
acheter votre énergie selon le moment où
vous l'achetez ça coûte plus ou moins
cher il ya un côté casino si je puis
dire lancer dans ses achats d'énergie
mais en tout cas c'est un vrai sujet et
quand on regarde ce qui se passe c'est
que ces hausses de dépenses liées à
l'énergie vont peser sur les ménages ce
que savait le prix de la cantine ça va
être le prix de la piscine qui assure ne
compte pas les dotations collectif de
n'augmente pas il faudra bien que les
communes trouve a effectivement des
moyens supplémentaires quelque part et
donc répercute ce prix sur l'usagé à un
moment c'est exactement comme en
économie la collectivité va prendre une
partie mais il ya une partie qu'on va
devoir faire porter sur l'usagé sinon
c'est une diminution de nos capacités
d'investissement s'est pas vertueux est
ce que le gouvernement a pris conscience
de ce phénomène qui se joue en ce moment
et nous on va l'aider j'ai bien entendu
hier l'appréciation très qualitative de
la mini sur la grande qualité du sénat
qui est souvent anticipateur libération
d'amour fatiha lors de la duration oui
alors on va passer aux travaux pratiques
c'est à dire que je pense avec
conviction et s'était mise en évidence à
cette table ronde passionnante qu'il
faut un bouclier tarifaire territoriales
c'est pour protéger les collectivités
encore une fois ci pour le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages vous nous
l'annonçait ici au coût de luc senay le
sénat va déposer des amendements au
projet de loi sur le sur le ps alors moi
je lâche acquis qui est en train d'être
présentés vous qui sera planté salah
alors moi je fais pas d'annoncé
solennelle au nom du sénat je dis
simplement que cette table ronde a mis
en évidence ce que chacun sentait qu'il
faut s'interroger sur un bouclier
tarifaire
territoria il s'agit pas de dire que
l'état doit tout payer mais est-ce qu'on
peut être raisonnable et comprendre
comme l'a dit madame la première
ministre que collectivité et à saintes
ou et que c'est pas la peine que le
gouvernement essaie d'alléger les la
surcharge et les maladresses aussi à
côté nous collectivités on n'y arrive
pas et on vient répercuter les dépenses
donc très rapidement il faudra étendre
les dispositifs qui sont maintenant là
prévu à la pompe ou prévu pour les
ménages les plus faibles les gros
rouleurs fera les étendre à certaines
collectivités en tout cas aujourd'hui il
faut intégrer une dimension de boucliers
le territoire qu'on va regarder comment
ce coup mais gardons une question aussi
car on a vu la fédération nationale des
collectivités concédantes et régies qui
regroupe les collectivités en charge des
singes duclos coal energy faire des
propositions notamment pour un retour
aux tarifs réglementés pour toutes les
collectivités un développement ambitieux
je cite des énergies renouvelables est
aussi une troisième proposition qu'ils
font c'est bien le maintien minimale
d'une alimentation d'électricité tout au
long de l'année et pas seulement l'hiver
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces
propositions oui sur les deux premières
alors la troisième aussi mes deux
premières je suis je suis parfaitement
d'accord le tarif régulé est quelque
chose de très positif parce
qu'aujourd'hui l'achat d'énergie c'est
une économie de casino et vous imaginez
les 35000 commune allait acheter de
l'énergie y'a pas de traders dans les
collectivités donc on a ce mouvement de
yo-yo qu'on ne maîtrise pas donc et
aussi une échelle de performance et
d'efficacité pour l'achat on voit dans
mon département d'ille-et-vilaine et un
syndicat départemental de l'énergie qui
permet d'acheter de l'énergie pour tous
publics au sein du milieu rural est de
sécuriser et d'empêcher les effets de
yo-yo de la bourse et que dire un
dernier mot sur et bien le développement
de ses nouvelles ces nouvelles pratiques
aussi en matière de consommation
l'énergie faut changer les pratiques bas
bien sûr faut changer nos comportements
et donc les commandes crime par exemple
dans un gymnase
peut-être que le chauffage dans les
salles de sport par moments ça me fait
interroger dans les écoles on peut
peut-être retarder de quelques jours
donc il faut être frugal oui il faut
diminuer notre il faut être sobre et
frugale et en même temps il faut prendre
de l'avancé sur le développement des
nouvelles énergies l'exemple de bénévent
l'abbaye petites communes de la creuse
où le maire et le conseil municipal
utilise les déchets d'une série qui
fabrique ces petits bardeaux de bois
qu'on va sur les toits du monde du mont
saint michel et qui produit son énergie
c'est rudement vertueux ted nugent et
bien
[Musique]